Hey, welcome to our six o'clock hour.
Got a very special show tonight.
One because you know and going around
the country and being in Texas,
Virginia, other places and um spending
time, we'd had some specials during the
uh our time in Texas. We would get
together particularly with some of the
younger people in our movement in the
MAGA and American first movement. And um
a couple things I've ascertained. Number
one, there's a real fascination out
there with the period called the
Crusades,
particularly among young people and
specifically among young men. But
there's not a lot of knowledge out there
about the Crusades. So I decided to
track down Raymond Ibraham
and Raymond's over in Europe right now,
but to say, "Hey, let's do a couple of
shows. I want to do shows that focus on
the Crusades and focus particularly the
Crusades
um for kind of young men and and
particularly about those who fought in
these uh in the Crusades and also why
they were called and kind of the history
of them. Raymond, you've done a trilogy
of of books that are I think Sword and
Scimitar is the first about the 1400year
war, and I mean real war, cultural,
social, political, economic, and kinetic
militarily against uh against Islam. Uh
you've then done the uh the book of uh
of those who who represented the West,
the heroes of the West in in these
various fights against you. So you take
it first generally and go through the
whole movement and the battles. Then we
go back to the personalities. I think
you have 10 or 11 personalities in this
defenders of the west are just
extraordinary. So you tell the story
again but through the lives of these
warriors which is so motivating and then
the last and probably my favorite part
of the topic when it comes to crusades
you take the military orders the book is
two swords for Christ and you take the
uh the hospitalers of St. John's and the
Knights Templar that came out of the
first crusade and uh you tell their
stories and so just extraordinary how on
different angles you tell the story so
people have a total comprehensive view.
The first thing I want to do is just
give the background because a lot of
times and you actually frame it the
correct way. People think, "Oh, the
crusade, you came and say the word on so
many Catholic schools throughout the
country, you know, after 911, they went
and took crusaders off of their their
uh, you know, as their logos had been
their mascots for decades and they said,
"Oh, no, no, no. That's so nivist.
That's so racist. That's zen xenophobic.
We got to call ourselves the bumblebees,
right? Not the crusaders." And but
because the story we we didn't
understand our own history in the elites
in this country and particularly in the
Bush administration when he called he
went to the mosque I think three day
three was as New York City lower
Manhattan still smoldering uh the
Pentagon still smoldering there's still
a smoking hole up there in Pennsylvania.
He goes and says oh no uh Islam is the
religion of peace which is the old hook
how they get the elites. Now we've seen
25 years later we have an active
jihadist Marxist movement in this
country that politically is growing in
strength every day. So give us the
context that that it just wasn't knights
in Normandy and and French rural
families and the aristocracy in in these
various European countries just decided
we're going to get together and march
and go to Jerusalem. It was an
invitation, but it was an invitation
because in context the rise of Islam was
really coming and choking off the holy
land. So can first off can you put us in
context what are the crusades and how
did they really start?
>> Sure Steve this is a an excellent and
complex and as you pointed out a very
timely topic and um it's it's a lot
deeper and more relevant than most
people can even begin to imagine
including myself. the more I study, the
more I connect the dots, the more I
realize that there's really a bigger
story here that has been intentionally
suppressed actually. And um so to answer
your, you know, your initial question
about the Crusades,
so you know, I I've already I've talked
about this a lot and I don't want to
take too much time, but essentially one
of the main problems which you just
touched on with the Crusades is not only
that they're presented in a vacuum,
which they are, but it's also in the in
the worst possible vacuum. So, like you
said, today it's, you know, the word
crusade is such a bad word. Uh, you
know, schools and have to get rid of it.
Mascots and this sort of thing, the
Bumblebee example. And even George Bush,
you're right. Uh, you know, he made the
whole Islamist peace thing. But even he
got in trouble because he used the word
crusade at one point. Uh, and of course,
he didn't mean military holy war. He
just meant like crusading a a good
endeavor, right? And even that he had to
backtrack and apologize for which again
underscores just how uh loaded that word
has become in a porative sense. Okay. So
the to fill the vacuum and to give us
some context before the first crusade
which was called for in 1095 you have
literally centuries of Muslim attacks on
what was once the Christian world and by
the time of the first crusade a lot a
huge chunk of that formerly Christian
territory is now Islamic. So this would
include all the older uh more advanced
more Christian regions in the seventh
century when Islam came onto the scenes
on the scene which would include all of
North Africa, Egypt all the way to
Morocco and all of the Middle East which
is all the all the modern states that
you can think of today basically uh well
from Turkey of course Anatolia all the
way down south, Lebanon, Syria, Iraq,
Jordan, Jordan and uh modern day Israel
Palestinian territories and so on and so
forth and a and a and a large part of
Arabia, even northern Arabia. Um, so
that all gets conquered in this massive
jihad, which again,
and and and and Persia and Babylon and
all the the course of
>> Persia, I mean, ancient civilizations,
Egypt, Babylon, Persia. I mean, you're
talking about some pretty big empires
that had pretty organized religions, did
they not?
>> Yes. Yes. into the Indis Valley as well.
And Persia had the Zarastrian religion
of course um and uh and and they
actually fell relatively early as well.
They fell around the same time that
Egypt in Syria did. Um and again, that's
probably because they were closer to the
Arabian homeland. So, you know, the the
the neighbors that were right there on
the doorsteps were the first to get
attacked and the first to get swallowed
up. But yes, um, usually what I'm
talking about now is primarily because
the jihad was so farreaching
historically, you have to really focus
on one aspect. So I usually try to focus
or I am at this point the
Christian/western
world. But of course, yes, Persia, the
Zorastrinists all the way into the far
east uh, and into subsaharan Africa also
through jihad. And these are all diverse
peoples with different civilizations and
religions all of whom got subsumed under
Islam. Okay. So that's basically the
context of uh if you fast forward now to
the first crusade everyone in Europe the
educated classes of course the clerical
classes the the popes uh the nobles
understood what had originally happened
to the Christian world in North Africa
and the Middle East. So they understood
that and it comes out in their
correspondences and letters and when
they're speaking too. They often say
things like when Egypt is comes back to
Christianity and things of that sort uh
for example. So now you come now we're
coming a couple decades before the first
crusade and you have another especially
savage um iteration of jihad under the
Seljic Turks and they are running a muk
in the Holy Land. they are committing
much worse atrocities than had even
occurred before then under the various
different Arab uh dynasties and
sultanates which themselves were also
pretty bad but now it's at a new level
um and you know the atrocities which we
have recorded and which were widely
spoken about from the pope from Pope
Urban to Peter the hermit to Robert of
Flanders to you know Emperor Alexius and
his daughter. So we have lots of records
of what was happening and you know to
call it horrific is is doesn't even do
it justice. I mean the things that are
written down are you know stuff of
nightmare where you know people are
being skinned alive their intrails are
being pulled out tied to a column and
they're whipped until all their intrails
are pulled out and fall down for example
women being systematically raped on top
of altars. um you know, anything you can
imagine. And it also spilled over onto
pilgrims because you still had European
pilgrims traveling to the Holy Land
during this time. It was understood that
was dangerous. That's part of the
pilgrimage. You know, you're you're
you're taking this you're undertaking
this very dangerous journey uh on a
pilgrimage to visit the holy sites and
uh you know, to engage in adoration and
possibly die while you're doing it. So,
and that is exactly what was happening
to them. And one of the more notable
instances occurred in 1064 because it's
widely attested where a a large German
pilgrimage went down and they got
attacked again by the Turks and everyone
was slaughtered and they talk about a
very uh attractive nun uh who was warned
not to go and then and she was gang
raped to death and then at the end it
says and those vile men did these sorts
of things to all all the pilgrims they
could ever reach. So this is the
backdrop of the first crusade which we
never ever hear. We just hear that out
of the blue. Uh you know I've quoted it
before probably to you as well. um John
Espazito, Georgetown academic, as this
memorable line where he basically says,
"Five centuries of peaceful coexistence
between Christians and Muslims elapsed
before an imperial papal power play led
to a series of so-called holy wars and
centuries of distrust and dislike
basically from Muslims who now have a
grievance because of what the crusaders
did." So until now in schools, in
colleges, uh you literally have people
in professors and books who teach that
that those centuries that I just told
you where Islam enexed, conquered,
subjugated and destroyed more than much
more than half of Christendom and as
well all those other civilizations in
Persia and so forth. Um this you have
professors telling people that that was
the highlight. That was like peaceful
coexistence between Christians and
Muslims until randomly Pope Urban and
and all these Franks decided just to go
and ruin it all because because well and
now so we have to fill in the vacuum.
Why? Well, because they're greedy,
because they're racist, because there's
they're imperialists. Because I suppose
they're Islamophobes uh at the risk of
being anacronistic and and this is now
what's supplanted the truth. So that I
want to go to ES I want to go as a
Georgetown alum. I want to go to
Espazito specifically when they say
peaceful coexistence and you look at I
want to remind the audience that since
really
uh I guess the um the first century
right uh I guess it's from 73 that
really the Jews have been driven out of
to a large extent uh the holy land and
particularly Jerusalem which was always
kind of the the the the crown jewel at
least in some parts greatness sometimes
they're gone. And so the the uh it's
really a Muslim controlled entity. When
you had peaceful coexistence,
if you did have peaceful coexistence is
because the Christians surrendered after
after these waves of jihad. There was
some resistance put up, but the
resistance essentially collapsed. I want
to say pretty quickly, but it was gone
relatively quickly. And it was really
submission, which is part of the way
Islam rolls. If you pay uh if you pay a
duty or if you pay a tax or if you
either convert or just submit to their
control, you can live at least somewhat
peacefully. They break out in in
violence all the time. But when Espaz
and this guy say it, it's because the
west was essentially the Christian part
of the west in that area was conquered
and and Islam controlled it. This is
except for Constantinople. Correct.
>> Yes. Correct. But if you and I I read
that book and you know it's very fuzzy.
I mean ultimately what you're saying is
that what Espazito is saying is that yes
Islam conquered subjugated these uh
populations and then they became
according to Islamic doctrine what's
called dimm and these are basically a
protected class usually Jews or
Christians who by paying tribute uh do
not get killed but they b essentially
live as at best secondass citizens. So
it's openly understood they're being
discriminated against.
>> Yes.
>> And that's something that they accept.
a peaceful coexistence only because they
they're not fighting back and when they
fight back exactly that's or not even
fighting back because
>> because they're not even asking for
equality. That's the whole point. They
know their place
>> as secondass citizens. It's almost like
you know pre-ivil rights movement
America 1800s. Okay, you can be black
and you know I won't kill you but as
long as you know your place kind of
thing. That mentality. the the the split
in the Roman Empire between
Constantinople and in and in and Rome
and Constantinople
uh as um as the new Rome, they weren't
particularly close. What did it take to
actually have Constantinople reach out
to Rome and reach out to the pope and
reach out to the Western Christendom in
the church and the really the noble
families, the nobility and the
aristocracy in Western Christianom to
say, "Hey, look, we got to put the flag
up here. Uh this is a problem and we
need your support. We need military
assistance." What what caused that?
because that was not an easy move for
them to do given how proud they were and
quite frankly some of the disdain they
had for the the older part of the Roman
Empire.
>> Yeah. No, that's that's correct. Um you
know uh especially think about it the
first crusades only about uh 40 years
right after the first schism uh around
1054.
So that again itself really highlights
the fact that uh you're right he
wouldn't have taken that extreme step
and swallowed his pride the Byzantine
emperor had it not been such a um dire
situation and if you look at a map you
have to recall Asia Minor what we call
today Turkey was right before this uh
you know 50 years before this it was
still primarily Christian Armenians
Greeks um and different groups and and
the western part was primarily under
Byzantine authority And then the Turks
come out of the east and then they start
causing you know havoc. I just recently
just to again put this in context uh you
know the Armenian genocide the
remembrance date was I think April 24th.
So as usual I did a little research and
writing about it and you know you start
realizing that actually the genocide
which most people the date usually is
1915 and 16th during World War I. But if
you really understand it, the the
genocide by the hands of Turks, Muslim
Turks against Christian Armenians in
that region goes back over a thousand
years ago. It goes to literally several
decades before the events that we're
describing in the first crusade because
it was then when the when the Turks
really rushed in and the you know they
came from the east. So who's in the east
of Anatolia? It's the Armenians and it
was greater Armenia. It was a much
larger region at the time. And the the
sources of again, you know, I was
telling you about the horrific
atrocities by the Turks. It's especially
against these Armenians. And they
literally talk about tens if not
hundreds of thousands of Christians. And
these are primary sources, eyewitness
accounts being just butchered in the
most sadistic way, thousands of churches
being ritually desecrated, set a flame,
crosses being broken and burned and ch
statues being decapitated, the whole
nine yards. Okay? Uh so that's what
these Seljic Turks were doing. And they
kept going further further westward into
Asia Minor until they were right there
on the straits right VCV Constantinople.
So that's how dire was and that's why
give me a second. Hang on. It just
wasn't individual bad guys. I want to
make sure people understand this. This
was just not individual bad ombres going
into a village or going to a church. You
used the term ritual desecration because
it was a it was a a weapon and
instrument of their conquering. Give me
a minute on ritual desecration. What did
they do?
>> Oh, okay. Think about what ISIS and
these groups do, which is not just
attack, kill, uh, infidels, but make
sure that they go and literally ritually
desecrate, let's say, a church and burn,
break the crosses and burn it and gouge
the eyes of icons and and behead
statues, which happens all the time in
Europe nowadays. Uh so we actually have
this the same pattern being shown which
the point ultimately is you know again
if you read a typical secondary modern
history it'll tell you it'll just say
yes the Turks ran in and and engaged in
violence and and suffer but they won't
they won't underscore this point they'll
miss it maybe they won't get they won't
connect the dots and realize okay this
wasn't just one group attacking another
group medieval warfare this was one
group that was propelled by an
ideological animus Okay, which is what
we call today jihadism. Um, and that
definitely comes out in the sources.
Both of them, the Muslim and the
Christian sources. The Muslim sources
boast about it. Okay, I'm thinking now
of they're talking about destroying this
major cathedral in Armenia and how they
sent uh this large crucifix to be as a
trophy to the Khalif in Baghdad. Okay.
And you see that still happening uh
today. I I've seen so many videos of
ISIS types, including right now what's
happening to Armenian churches at the
hands of Azrabjan, where they're
literally erasing them from their
ancient territories that were seated
recently from the the 2020 war. So yes,
bottom line is definite ideological
animus was infused in these jihadist
attacks, though they won't come out in
typical history books. It'll just seem
like one group attacking another.
>> What was the call for help? What was the
call for help? Where did it go? And what
was the response in the Christian West?
>> So um the emperor and others of course
reached out for to the pope himself. But
uh we also have letters from the emperor
to people like Count Robert of Flanders
who was a friend of his because uh you
know despite what we what we always hear
this sort of ideological divide between
Eastern Orthodox and Western Catholics
wasn't as stringent or real as we like
to think sometimes. And there was a lots
of cooperation that went on. And to your
average lay person certainly they didn't
even understand just like they don't
today uh the schismatic fights and what
they were about. Um but so we have these
letters and correspondences of basically
calling for help calling for aid saying
you know this is happening to fellow
Christians. And again, the idea that um
you're asking me, so what caused them to
respond? And I think it's because
learning that such atrocious um cruelty
was being inflicted on fellow
Christians. And see, that's the point.
You know, the Franks and the West are
Catholics, whereas the East, the
Byzantines, the Orthodox, Armenians are
are Orthodox. And that didn't at any in
any way, shape or form, that never comes
up. You never hear uh you know right
before the first crusade that there was
some debate or even the pope himself was
saying yeah well they're heretics they
have it coming to them. Okay that never
appears and again it just shows you that
in reality despite these supposed
schisms uh which were real uh the
average Christian even the pope you know
why did pope Urban II uh comply and he
didn't require anything he didn't tell
uh the emperor Alexis oh now you have to
uh agree to papal authority or anything
of that sort. Okay. So, the reason I
believe they were propelled to it is
just shocked at the horror that what was
being inflicted on fellow Christians,
shocked at what was happening to
Christian pilgrims, shocked at what was
happening to the holy land, the holy
supplr, church of the resurrection, uh
which had been destroyed before and was
being attacked periodically, even it was
after it was rebuilt. Um, lots of
sacrilege. So, it was actually what
propelled them and historians now know
this. Again, this is one of those
stories that was, you know, uh, much
fabricated, the the motivation, the
cause. You can still grab history books
by August voices like Sir Steven
Runsman, who's a great writer, and uh,
you know, he'll give you the idea that
he's that basically, yes, they responded
because it was an economic opportunity,
and uh, you know, it was an adventure
and there was all these second sons who
had no uh um, nothing to inherit and so
they had to go there. Now historians
after careful research, decades worth
going through vast archives and
correspondences and letters, it's become
abundantly clear uh unequivocally so
that these men were first and foremost
propelled by a sincere pious uh desire
to help their fellow man. Okay, it was
actually love. Okay, altruism, the the
the muscular variety where Jesus himself
says no greater commandment than to love
God with all your heart and to love your
fellow man. So they were loving God
during the crusades because
>> the pope the pope specifically focused
and actually went and gave this amazing
um I guess sermon uh in the fields. But
there definitely if you look at the
first crusades and look where he went,
there's a focus on the Normans in
Normandy. We call them the Franks and
they were called the Franks, but the
Normans, why are the Normans
uh why are they kind of the center of
gravity, I would say, for the first
crusade. And when the pope had to look
at the whole universe of what he was
going to do, he focused on nor the
Normans and Normandy.
>> Yeah. Well, the Normans are they're
they're characters. Um, so as we know,
the Normans are the descendants of the
Northmen, the Vikings, who eventually, I
think with some sort of treaty with one
of Charlemagne's descendants, settled in
Normandy, um, in northern France
essentially and were Christian and, um,
but I think they kept something of the
Viking spirit still alive in them and
they were a very, um, you know, Bellose
lot, but they were also they were still
amongst them. You had very Christian uh,
piety. So they made for a very uh they
they they were the ideal crusader
because they were adventurous, they were
militant, they were religious and pious.
Um and they seem to have been giants. A
lot of them were really large and and
the way they're described in the sources
um among them Boand uh who ends up he's
in the he's one of the leaders of the
first crusade and he ends up becoming
essentially the prince of Antioch after
it was conquered in 1098. And Anna, the
daughter of the aforementioned Byzantine
emperor, describes him and you can just
tell she's awed by him. She's just, you
know, there was a he's just this giant
and just kind of like he terrified her
just looking at him. So I imagine there
was a lot of that going on um that these
eastern peoples and the Byzantines had
not seen.
It is true that amongst the the Franks
generally that's the word even in the
Arabic today when they talk about
crusaders or today in Arabic if you talk
if you want to say someone is European
or Europeanized or looks European you
say Frank al frge because that's uh in
the Arabic mentality goes all the way
back to the crusades that's what a white
person is or a Christian is and
generally that was the Frankia okay but
the north of course you have the Norman
who were different in their own slight
culture But of course as time goes by
they get they do become conflated with
the Franks uh to some degree. But yeah
they again they do stand out um they
stand out for their their marshall
prowess that's for sure as do other
Franks.
>> We're going to get to that in a second.
>> War room. Here's your host Steven K.
>> Brother Ibraham Ibraham is with me the
author of a trilogy of amazing books
about the Crusades. We're talking now
about the crusades for young men. We're
going to pivot now to the first crusade.
Couple of the big personalities and what
happened. Incredible books. So, well,
they read like novels. If and if you
want to give young people in your life
and particularly young men in your life,
I strongly recommend you always start
with volume two, Defenders of the West,
these vignettes about these great
warriors. Uh, every young man you have
will be jacked up after they read it.
the whole trilogy you got to read
starting with the overall war uh sword
and scimitar and then you've got uh
defenders of the west and then you've
got um uh two swords of Christ about the
military uh orders the the the monks of
the knights templar and the hospatalers
uh St. John just enormous incredible
stories. The Normans and the reason is
this is a multi-part series we're going
to do Raymond. The Normans are so
important for the whole story. They had
just and this is the Normans just to
keep it simple are really the Vikings
mixed in with French gals, right? It's
they came down and went up the the
rivers and into France and uh and they
became a military powerhouse. They
eventually took Malta and Sicily and
they had a whole empire based on their
military prowess. They took England in
1066 at Hastings. They defeated the
Saxons and then had a role. And of
course, if you you read, you know, if
you if you're a kid raised on Robin
Hood, the Normans were considered not
the good guys, right? They were kind of
hammers. They they they had a certain
Viking way about them. But that's why
the pope particularly knew that, hey,
the odds are so long that I'm going to
form a Christian army in the west and
march that army or take it by sail to
one of the most inhospitable places in
the world, the Middle East. And I'm
going to take on uh a group that has
essentially conquered most of the known
world in their area uh in in in five or
six hundred years. That would be the uh
the Islamic forces now with the Seljic
Turks, but they had already conquered so
much coming out of Saudi Arabia. The
odds are that are like a billion to one.
I guess I'm going to go find the baddest
ombres I can find, and that's the
Normans. Particularly, you had this
system where the the the lead son gets
everything. You've got to you've got
these other lads who are not in order of
going to control anything and they're a
little rowdy. And so the the the culture
has a problem with the the male marshall
attitudes of these people. Why does the
pope decide to go there? And what's the
message he gives in that field?
>> No, just I'm going to answer that, but
before I do, because you brought up a
very interesting point about the Normans
and the and the Battle of Hastings and
you know, they did something else
actually, these Normans a little around
the time of the Battle of Hastings and
before the first crusade, which is they
conquered Islamic Sicily. uh reconquered
it. And that was also another pivotal
event that is a sort of precursor uh to
the first crusade. And it happened. My
my dates are a little fuzzy, but I want
to say 1060s uh or maybe 1070s uh where
where they go in and they conquer from
the Muslims, the Arabs, the Sarissens at
the time. So that may as well have been
one of the reasons that someone like
Pope Urban II did target them because
they already had uh they had that
experience. They've proven their medal
against the Muslims and were successful.
They were proving it in England as well
against the Saxons. So definitely he saw
them as the creme de la creme of
marshall
violence. Uh as to your other question,
your main question, um this is also the
time of, you know, the the truths of God
and the peace of God and there and the
church is trying to basically tame these
men, the Normans, the Franks in general,
um from fighting amongst each other. And
this is why uh part of the message of
Pope Urband and and other ecclesiastical
authorities during the right around the
first crusade was, you know, okay, you
you have this violence, this violent
impulse. Well, let's marshall it and use
it for a good cause in defense of the
widow, of the orphan, of the poor
pilgrim who's traveling. Why if fight
the actual enemies of Christ, not your
fellow brethren? And I think that very
much resonated with them because it's
true. It makes sense obviously. Um and
this is you see this now as a major
shift uh the first crusade whereby you
know knights and these landed baronss
and normans are who normally fight with
each other um because they have a
proclivity for that sort of thing now
start uh gearing it towards a much more
noble cause which is fighting uh again
uh in in keeping with Christ's
commandment for their fellow man and for
God himself uh by liberating the holy
land. So I think that is definitely one
of the reasons it resonated with these
particular kinds of men
>> and he sent emissary now to preach to
preach that gospel essentially that we
have to recruit there but it's very
specific that it's you you can walk us
through it but they were actually
calling for the organization of a
Christian army to essentially go on a
crusade a pilgrimage to the Middle East
and take back not simply the holy land
but to take back Jerusalem as the great
poem I think is from Tasso in the middle
ages. Jerusalem delivered sir.
>> Yeah. And and this you know here we
really come to one of the very first
obvious obvious points that most people
don't notice. Most historians won't
mention the people who will tell you
that the crusades were waged for cynical
reasons. It was about second sons trying
to get land and this sort of thing. If
that was the case, uh you know what what
they're doing these people with this
interpretation is they're completely
missing the extreme labor that went on
that went handinhand with crusading. So
first of all a lot of these men who were
landed and uh were rich and Godfrey of
Buon Raymond of Tulus who were captains
of the first crusade they actually
mortgaged their land and some of them
were in debt just to raise money so they
can go crusading and they already had
land. They lost their titles. They gave
it up. they um just to go and fight in
the holy land. Uh one number two, you
know what? Why can't they if you want to
be cynical, why don't you just attack
your neighbor like they had been doing?
Why travel thousands of miles on
horseback or on foot for the average
pilgrim through dangerous enemy hostile
enemy territory uh where most crusaders
and the people who went on the first
crusade about 70% of them either died or
actually gave up and went home just from
the actual from the journey itself
because of the starvation of the disease
uh lack of water. Uh when you hear about
these stories about you know crusaders
turn into cannibalism it's because of
that because of extreme duress where
they were in positions of starvation and
they would you know eat corpses. Muslims
had done the same as well for example
during the siege of Constantinople in
717. Um but so my point is there's a lot
of easier ways to have gone about it
than doing this. And also another very
obvious difference between the crusaders
and the Muslims which really highlights
the uh the idealism or the idealistic
nature of crusaders. That is to say that
they weren't out just to conquer. They
were out specifically out to reconquer
the holy land itself. And that's not
what Muslims ever did. What Muslims
always did is right from their first
base beginning in Arabia, they attacked
their immediate neighbors Egypt, Syria,
Iran, Persia. And then once they
consolidated those areas, then they
attack the next region. So from Egypt,
they would attack Libya and so forth.
And that's the smart way to do it, of
course, because uh you have your
reserves right there. You're not thrown
in the middle of enemy enemy territory.
That's why it was much more successful
and pragmatic the Islamic conquest
because it wasn't idealistic. It was
just who's the easiest target? Oh, it's
the guy right next to me. I'm gonna
attack him. The crusaders didn't do
that. They weren't out to conquer
anyone. They were out to liberate the
very important piece of holy land to
them uh because that's where Christ
walked. That's where he was crucified,
resurrected, um and that sort of thing.
So, so it was very idealistic. They
threw themselves in the lines. Then
getting there itself was a horrific
journey that most of them died from and
they lost so much money. So ultimately
what we're saying here is that for the
first crusade definitely and most of the
other ones as well too but definitely
because we're talking about the first
crusade the number one reason was
sincere piety.
>> Okay sincere piety. Let's let's I want
to talk I want to drill down on a second
because I think this is a good lesson
for young men.
>> These uh men were hard. They were hard
men. These guys were fighters. They were
warriors. Like you said the Normans had
already conquered Sicily. they had um
taken at Hastings beaten the Saxons who
were also from Viking blood. So there
was the these they're they're taking on
the toughest and they're beating them
and and other people associated with the
Normans. That's not simply the Normans.
These men were also because in the
medieval and the Middle Ages um
worldview, they were also deeply
Christian, right? But they had faults.
They they they knew they had sinned.
part of this it because indulgences
later got so out of control, it was one
of the reasons that the the reform of
the church uh got traction from Luther
and others about these indulgences. Was
it not something that the church said
that if you go on this crusade and
you're there and you go all in on trying
to take back the holy land and
particularly Jerusalem that you will get
a special indulgence, you will get
saved. that and these guys in their own
hearts knowing that they were devout
Christians but not perfect people that
this kind of combined two things saying
hey look with all the problems I'm going
to have if I sign up for this I got a
path to I got a path to uh I I got a
path to eternal life
yeah um a lot of that is correct but I
would caution people to keep in mind
that this has to be understood through a
Catholic paradigm and it wasn't about
salvation it was about uh avoiding ing
um uh purgatory or lessening it in as
much as they could. So uh and this is
actually one of the reasons people try
to attack uh the crusades because they
they make it sound as oh the pope was
selling salvation. Well, he wasn't.
Actually, the idea of salvation was
still that it was through Christ,
through baptism, through grace and and
so forth. But because of the Catholic
notion of purgatory, unless you lived an
absolutely sinless life, you would still
have to go there, which was extreme
suffering after after this life. It was
temporal. It was temporary. But it just
shows you that to these people, they
took it seriously and they were trying
as much as they could to avoid that long
and less in lessening the suffering in
purgatory, which obviously came
purgatory became a big issue in the
reformation. But in the purgatory,
they're making the direct connection
that your your profession of combat arms
can lessen your time in purgatory.
That's a different pitch. That's a pitch
that they people hadn't heard before.
That when you read the history, they go,
"Hang on a second. Let me get this
right. I'm a warrior. I I'm I'm a
basically a professional, right?" uh
because everybody there was kind of they
they were advanced amateurs or or
professionals that in the in the
profession of combat arms, I can
actually lessen my time in purgatory and
get to heaven quicker. Correct.
>> Yes. And uh the flip side of that is
because they were armed warriors, they
knew they were going to go to purgatory
because in engaging in so much violence
and bloodshed, much of which of course
was not just
>> um you know, so so they were trying to
use their they were trying to use their
weakness, which was making them spend a
lot of time in purgatory to help them
get out of spending so much time in
purgatory by instead of engaging in
unrighteous violence, engaging in just
warfare.
>> Just give me a couple of examples. We'll
do this in the second episode in more
detail as we talk about the process of
the first crusade, but just give me a
couple of the personalities that jump
off the page at you that that young men
are fascinated by the crusades. But who
are who are some of the big
personalities you would like people to
focus on, particularly in your book,
Defenders of uh Defenders against uh uh
of the West?
>> West. Yeah, definitely the first one
because I, you know, in my in in the
privacy of my own mind, I had to
determine who were the most impressive.
And chapter one of that book, Defenders
of the West, is dedicated to Godfrey of
Buon, Duke Godfrey. Um, and he is really
paradmatic of what we're talking about.
Very idealistic, very impressive. He was
landed. He was the Duke of Lorraine. Um,
he was he was uh he wasn't the oldest
son, but he became Duke through uh his
uncle actually favored him for whatever
reason. and made him his uh heir. And uh
despite that, he sold everything,
mortgaged everything, raised uh whatever
money he could, raised an army, and went
on to the first crusade. Very pious
according to the sources, including
contemporary sources. And again, this is
the irony. He's one of the men that when
I was reading, I mentioned Sir Steven
Runsman. And Runsman uses him as an
example of na a naive leader. He should
have never been a leader. He was he
liked to listen to monks and engage in
uh theological debates and uh you know
Ronman just completely condemns that as
so silly as opposed to his brother uh
Baldwin who he he presents as being more
politically a droid and whatnot. But
when you read the sources, what you get
is a humble man, a pious man, uh strong
man. Uh he you know he we I have I I
quote how he was raised him and his
brother by their mother and it's very
typical for knights you know very from
age from birth to about seven. It was a
very this is when they learn about God
and religion and if they're going to
learn any letters it would be around
that time and then from seven to about
14 they would be you know given to some
uh family relative almost like uh a
mentorship where they start learning all
sorts of things including etiquette but
also horse riding and um and discipline
okay and doing duties. And then from
about 14 on, this is when they're
really, you can see them as squires and
they're engaged in full-on combat
warfare. Not exactly what kids do today,
you know, with their game boys in video
in video games, but uh so they would be
engaged in that sort of thing. Very
edifying, very fulfilling until about 21
when they would were were kned
essentially. And this is the same story
for Godfrey. But we also learn that
through his youth, he was just seen as
an immensely stalwart warrior. Um
according they'll say legend but
according to the sources multiple
sources with one sword stroke he split a
Turk uh vertically okay and one part he
a Turk on a horse and one part slipped
off and the other part dangled on the
horse and uh you know all the Muslims
and the Turks freaked out because it ran
back into uh Antioch looking like that.
So he fought a bear again. These are
true stories. They sound
>> instead of instead of naive, if the
military orders, if the Templars have
been around or the Knights of St. John
have been around, he would have been the
type of
>> he was almost monastic. I mean, the
reason Rensman goes after him is naive.
He's a immensely spiritual. He's almost
like a Zen warrior, right? He's a very
very deeply esoteric Christianity too.
He's he's very much more the Orthodox
church and the Western church. Not so
much just about the ceremonies and the
customs. He's really uh taken in the
spiritual nature of the desert fathers,
the spiritual nature of the West. He's
an immensely spiritual uh crusader,
right, or knight at the time.
>> I would completely agree with those
characterizations. I think they're very
spot-on. And uh he he he was I think
even when I wrote Two Swords of Christ,
I mention him as a sort of um
predecessor of the Knights of the
Temple. He's the kind of guy they were
modeling because he also was monastic
that he never got married because he was
constantly involved in warfare due to
his piety. He was elected to become the
first king of Jerusalem and he refused
it on uh on condition that he not be
called king and instead be called
defender or protector of the holy supplr
and he famously said uh I will not wear
a crown of gold where my savior wore a
crown of thorns. Okay. So that's that's
the kind of man that he was and he
continued fighting and when he was
elected people think this is uh again
it's funny because we were told oh they
went to the holy land to conquer land
this was about land actually a lot of
them once they had liberated all they
wanted to do was go back home including
Godfrey. So it was seen as a a sacrifice
to stay there instead of going back home
to your loved ones and safety and your
lands you stay in this desert uh with
hostile people all around you in
constant warfare. not exactly a great
deal uh you know or great bargain uh but
he chose it he opted for it and he died
he only lasted for a year before he
finally died and and the re and without
giving too much away but there's good
reason to believe he was poisoned by a
Muslim
>> but that's the paragatic type of
character
>> I want to get into all that real quickly
let's go through all three books I want
people for for this exercise the second
book is probably the best but the other
two and I tell people get get all three
of them because you get the overview of
the war and you can see so many um
relevant kind of facts of the day. The
second volume right there, the defenders
of of the west and the third volume
about the two military orders, the
Knights of St. John and the Knights
Templar. Just give me a give me a minute
or so on all three of the books. Uh your
research, the years writing it, your
great love of this uh of this time and
this tale.
Sure.
>> Thanks, Steve, for the opportunity. And
just to follow up on what you said, the
three books can be read in any order.
And so, um, for someone to grab
Defenders of the West, if they really
want heroism, inspiring stories, uh,
which are based on, of course, the long
story, the long war between Islam and
the West. Yeah, you're right. Defenders
of the West Phil fills in the spot. The
first book, if you want to read them
all, and if you want to really get it
in, the first book would give you the
most general introduction. It's assumed
that, you know, the reader doesn't know
much. So the first book sword and
scimitar really covers the long history
of conflict between Islam and the west
from the rise of Islam in the 7th
century up until America's first war
with Isl first war as a nation which is
the the first barbar wars. Um so that'll
give you the lay of a land defenders of
the west will it's the same it's the
same terrain but uh told through the
eyes and lives of uh these various
defenders that I highlight. Each chapter
is basically a mini biography and the
two swords of Christ is like both of
them. It's really this is the one that's
focused on the crusades because even
though I wasn't writing about the
crusades, I was writing about the
military orders and they are inseparable
from the crusades. So really the book if
you wanted the deepest dive of the
crusades, it's the two swords of Christ.
But it also gets into the religious uh
uh theology behind it, the rationale,
the Christian rationale of warfare that
we're talking about because so many
people don't how can you be a Christian
and fight back. Well, you're going to
see that these guys were the as pious as
they come kind of like what I just even
more so from Godfrey what I described
because they literally took vows of
monks but they were just the most you
know like berserk on the field in
warfare. So how did they rationalize it?
So, I definitely get into the theology
of of of that, but it even goes way
beyond the the first crusade because at
least one of those orders outlasted the
first crusade, the crusades, and
actually still alive till this day, the
Knights of St. John, of course. Um, so
yeah, thanks for the opportunity. I I
got into this field because you could
just see how appealing this sort of
thing is. And at one point, we're going
to talk about why it's so appealing and
why it's being suppressed.
>> Uh, social media, where do people go? We
go to Amazon to get the books where they
go to social media and your website.
>> My website is raymond.com
and uh you'll see links to social media
and so forth and definitely check out my
YouTube channel just by my my name. You
can also type in holy war because that's
what I I deal with. Uh but my website
should have all of my uh social media
links.
>> Thank you, brother. Appreciate you.
>> Yeah,
>> look forward to
part two. Thank you, sir.
>> These books are amazing. give uh volume
two, get it for a young man in your
life. You'll see it changed right away
as he reads about the great defenders of
the Christian West.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.